n
hiver. On parle de centaines de
nouveaux cas comme nous dit
Normand Grondin.
- Il y a du virus respiratoire
qui n'est pas la covid 19 qui
fêtent que plein d'enfants qui
ont des maladies.
- C'est un autre problème qui
préoccupe les urgences des
hôpitaux pour enfants. Le virus
respiratoire VRS.
- La majorité des patients on se
virus. On est vraiment dans une
pandémie à nous.
- Certains d'entre eux sont très
malades.
- Elle allait bien hier médecin
mis après à tousser comme un
phoque comme on dit. Ce n'est
pas une bonne toux.
- La santé de la petite s'est
rapidement détériorée.
- J'avais un rhume et je crois
que je lui ai donné mais elle
est toute petite elle a un petit
corps. Ça s'est transformé. Elle
a besoin d'oxygene.
- On comptait à peine 36 cas en
juillet au Québec. On dépasse
les 504 deux mois plus tard.
- Ça cause numéro un
d'hospitalisation sur les jeunes
enfants. C'est beaucoup,
beaucoup plus fréquents que la
covid.
- Pour les enfants plus âgés, il
est rarement un problème. Pour
les tous petits, c'est plus
compliqué. La majorité des
patients hospitalisés sont des
patients avec des difficultés
respiratoires et d'hydratation.
Il y a aussi beaucoup d'enfants
qui sont malades avec d'autres
conditions chroniques qui
compensent parce qu'ils ont
attrapé ce virus.
- Un à 2 % des enfants atteints
sont hospitalisés.
Les spécialistes n'avaient
jamais vu ça.
- Étant donné qu'il n'y avait
pas de VRS, presque pas
d'infection dans les derniers
mois, la population en général
est beaucoup plus susceptible à
cette infection.
- On a eu un boom de natalité
pendant la pandémie. Il y a
beaucoup de jeunes bébés qui
s'en viennent. Ils ont des
frères et des soeurs qui vont à
la garder et maintenant.
- On demande aux parents
d'éviter les urgences autant que
possible. Histoire de laisser
plus de place aux cas graves.
- On n'est pas sorti du bois.
Elle est capable de respirer par
elle-même. On est entre de